wer träumt nicht davon in den
langweiligen und anstrengenden job
hinter sich zu lassen und bequem
tausende euro von zu hause auf dem sofa
frieden kein lästiger chef kein frühes
aufstehen urlaub und arbeiten wann und
wo man es möchte der internetseite fall
war verspricht genau das und zwar ohne
dass man in der ausbildung oder andere
zertifikate vorzeigen muss sogar schüler
können darüber aufträge aus aller welt
annehmen und von überall selbstständig
geld verdienen aber vielleicht ist das
ganze und wie viel geld kann man damit
wirklich verdienen ich mache das
experiment eine woche werde ich
dokumentieren wie ich mich beifall war
anmelde und jedenfalls und viele
aufträge wie möglich erledigen um zu
sehen wie viel geld dabei am ende
herausspringen
dieses video wird von safed ist
unterstützt einer software die jedem
selbständigen das leben leichter machen
wenn man auf einmal geld ausgeben möchte
kann man sich aus unzähligen
dienstleistern auswählen wen man gerne
hätte und darauf aber geld verdienen
möchte muss man sein auftreten möglichst
attraktiv für kunden gestalten und dafür
will man als aller erstes mal ein bild
aus was uns hier richtig gut
repräsentiert ich glaub ich glaube damit
werden wir keinen einzigen kunden finden
deswegen nicht ich mache mal über das
eis gilt es wenn wir natürlich einfach
alles aus und überall experten etwas
nicht versteht sich von selbst
jetzt fehlen uns noch die gags da werde
ich mal anfangen mit videobearbeitung
jeder art visual effects und youtube
videos schneiden und dann können sich
leute zwischen diesen drei sachen als
ausdruck oder uns eben über diese klicks
finden
[Musik]
ähnlich wie bei youtube müssen wir jetzt
auch noch mental einstellen damit die
leute auch wissen was sie erwartet und
auch ein kleines preview video damit die
leute sehen aber okay das hat er schon
gemacht der hat ja was drauf oder eben
auch nicht
und da suche ich jetzt ein paar geile
sachen raus die ich in der vergangenheit
schon mal gemacht habe politik allen
sachen die linke nicht sehr weit in der
vergangenheit da ist wohl jemand voll
geworden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt ziemlich viel zeit rein
gesteckt weil hier ist der erste
eindruck natürlich alles hier setzt der
visual effects geht mit den stufen basic
standard und premium der kandidaten
aussuchen wie viel arbeit wenig wie
komplex holz sein mit diesen preisen
nicht jetzt ausgewählt hat dann würde
ich mich selber ausbeuten lassen so
günstig sollte niemand arbeiten ich
mache das einfach und schnell kunden zu
kriegen damit ich die ersten bewertungen
bekommen damit ich eben dann mit diesen
bewertungen die anderen kunden anlockt
die mir dann eben mehr geld zahlen den
rest des ersten tages habe ich damit
zugebracht produktivitäts bücher zu
lesen da ich ja noch keine aufträge
bekommen habe aber trotzdem etwas
produktives machen wollten etwas
produktives machen wollte jetzt weiter
zu tag 2 gucken wir mal ob beifall war
mittlerweile schon was tatsächlich 55
dollar trainereffekt möchte der ganz
schnell möchte die haben deswegen noch
mal zehn euro extra wäre nur noch zwölf
stunden zeit also wir müssen uns daran
halten hey kannst du denn hin
widersetzen für den clip im anhang ich
hätte gerne beeindruckende wolken am
himmel hinter den vögeln und eine
epische farb bearbeitung an die arbeit
das habe ich mir für den hintergrund
dieses bild mit wolken rausgesucht das
wird ziemlich gut anpassen mit
verschiedenen effekten hab ich jetzt ein
himmel hier freigestellt und das passt
natürlich überhaupt nicht in dieser
himmel muss erst mal auf unserer firma
hat reagiert track werden damit es auch
da bleibt wo es hingehört so einer
dreiviertelstunde sieht der kippe zu
hause ich schicke ihnen jetzt mal ab und
guckt was der kunde davon hält eine
halbe stunde ist vergangen jetzt schon
feedback erhalten ich habe ihn
beauftragt weil ich hochqualitatives sky
replacement in unter einem tag gebraucht
habe und der verkäufer hat in unter zwei
stunden abgeliefert ich habe jetzt ihren
profit fünf sternen dadurch sind unser
profil schon deutlich besser aus und
vielleicht kommt dadurch die nächsten
aufträge um so schneller
ich habe gerade gesehen dass man als
kunde auch fall wenn ich nur nach den
diensten anderer suchen kann sondern
dass man auch gezielt aufträge
ausschreiben kann für die sich dann
andere bewerben können und da habe ich
ein paar lustige und auch ein paar
interessante sachen gefunden
ich suche simple ist die teamarbeit ich
will einfach dass jemand mein gesicht
immer fetter wachsen lässt während ich
ein stück pizza ist ja oder der suche
nach insgesamt fitter und zwar soll der
benutzer dabei aussehen wie ein baby mit
einem hut und revolver klar ich will
dass jemand einen total realistischen
unten total unrealistischen clip von der
macht während ich einen rat mache nur
eure informationen nicht wie kunde 75
kilo und hat tatsächlich die letzten
vier jahre kein rad mehr gemacht der das
kann ich jetzt bei vielen verschiedenen
leuten beworben hoffentlich meldet sich
da von einer vier mal gespannt
das ist gerade 0 30
ich wollte schon lange im bett sein aber
ich hatte gerade noch eine idee und wie
man das macht alles online an chip für
near unternehmer lifestyle mensch bleibt
man auch gerne mal länger wach und zwar
ist die idee als ich ins segeln bitte
mach ich glaube das ist echt cool sowohl
für unternehmen als auch für
privatpersonen sind deswegen werde ich
dann auch einen blick erstellen und
später dafür sogar noch von 50 euro die
wir heute eingenommen haben facebook
werbung schalten und dann morgen
vielleicht schon ganzen der aufträge zu
haben es ist gerade 32 und wir haben vor
in einer nachricht gekriegt unserem
geschäft boomt das ist nur nachricht von
andere leute die wir vorhin
angeschrieben haben unser zweiter
richtige auftrag das ist jemand der
gerne so ein konter hätte der von oben
runter erzählt könnte sich auch ein
projekt runterladen aber ich mache sie
natürlich gerne und sozial der richtige
aufträge ich freue mich richtig sind
fünf euro daher immerhin schickt die
märz das angebot dann muss erst mal auch
annehmen ja und dann haben wir unsere
nächsten fünf euro
ihren 24 ich habe den job mit dem
service erstellt und ich habe dich fest
angestellt mal gucken wie sich das
entwickelt ob morgen schon das ist
aufträge lassen so ich bin jetzt wieder
back in office hat sogar ein hemd an der
recht schick hier ist ja auch seriöses
unterfangen was wir haben und es gibt
gute nachrichten
wir haben ja einen neuen auftrag für den
10 er möchte einen instagram filter
möchte der haben
der filter soll ihren ist an die backe
machen das ist es war so klar dazu
kommen würde geil ich glaube das letzte
mal was unsere größeres als das gemacht
habe habe ich noch viel gearbeitet heute
war ein extrem produktiver tag auf weil
ich habe dieses kleine stern video
erstellt ich habe diesen kleinen
countdown programmiert zudem habe ich
einen etwas merkwürdigen hintergrund
filter stellt der aber trotzdem eine
menge spaß gemacht hat und gerade mein
letztes feedback für heute erhalten
great job hat genau das gemacht was er
sagte dass er tun würde perfekt fünf
sterne und damit würde ich sagen haben
heute ganz viele aufträge erfolgreich
abgeschlossen und es wirklich verdient
jetzt endlich mal schon um halb eins ins
bett zu gehen
morgen ist freitag und damit der letzte
tag der arbeitswoche und dann werden wir
wissen wie viel kohle wir innerhalb so
kurzer zeit gescheffelt haben aber an
eine harte realität deshalb ständig
science haben viele von euch bisher noch
gar nicht gedacht steuern
ich glaube jeder selbständige kann
nachvollziehen wie es hieß es
stundenlang vor dutzenden papieren zu
sitzen die darauf warten sortiert
kategorisiert und bearbeitet zu werden
tut mir fast auf der stelle in fünf
youtuber ein die das schon mal nicht so
nachvollziehen können und deswegen vom
finanz und ordentlich auf den deckel
gekriegt haben als ich vor kurzem das
thema einer buchhaltungssoftware namens
es bei mir gemeldet hat dachte ich mir
zuerst buchhaltung dass er das
langweiligste von dem ich jemals gehört
habe zwölf sekunden später
es ist ja das alles geiste von dem ich
jemals gehört hat und ich meine es ernst
anstatt sich durch zeit ort und mit
unzähligen seelenlosen papieren
durchzugehen die dich an starten und
sich fragen warum du dich nicht schon
vor wochen um sie gekümmert hast du dich
schon von aber auch gerüchte kümmert die
combo pop und dann statt das alles durch
zu machen das nennt man sich einfach
einen beleg scannten mit der app ein
lesebuch und ist automatisch im system
drin
self test erkennt daraus einfach
automatisch die rechnungsnummer den
rechnungssteller den rechnungsbetrag
dann auch schon eine kategorie angeben
und habe direkt in ordnung ohne viel
arbeit und mit geilen statistiken und
der papierkram
also wenn ihr selbst gar nichts halt
oder ist gerade werden wollte und ihn
fragen was mache ich mit steuern seien
gift das die ersten 14 tage sind kommen
bei kostenlosen müssen keine
zahlungsinformationen angeben und gerade
für anfänger denkt euch nicht mich
verdienen ja gar nicht so viel geld dass
ich schon egal neben dem finanzamt ist
es nicht egal egal ob besetzt 1000 euro
oder nur 50 euro sind die links für die
kostenlosen 14 tagen ist in der
beschreibung ich facebook werbung die
ich geschrieben habe hat mich ein
bisschen überrascht und zwar mit 45 euro
fast 100.000 leute damit erreicht und
davon haben auch 1700 leute auf unseren
link geklickt allerdings hat sich sehr
verändert dazu entschieden unseren
auftrag zu geben auf fall war ist heute
ein bisschen mau aktualisiert schon die
ganze zeit aber wie kriegen wir keine
anfragen rein was sie natürlich auch die
schattenseiten deshalb ja nicht sein
sven als einfach keinen auftrag
reinkommt hand vornehmen und hat auch
kein geld
der letzte tag hat angebrochen wir haben
eine neue bestellung aber gott sei dank
der möchte auch einen instagram väter
und das internet wird er soll
er sollte den kopf vom benutzer durch
eine toilette ersetzen ich weiß echt
nicht was ich auch fall war für leute
dort haben aber über 85 euro kind gesagt
der besten überhaupt den kopf du die
toilette zu ersetzen wären toiletten
fällt dazu gemacht hat
öffne dass ich dann auch die toilette zu
öffnen war ziemlich das ist wirklich
lustig also es ist wirklich lustig soll
ich warte jetzt noch ein bisschen
hoffentlich kommt nochmal was damit wir
ein richtig fettes sümmchen am ende
haben das glück hat mir leider nicht
dass wir haben jetzt am ende dieser
reise die ehre zugucken wie viel wir
jetzt durch fall war wirklich verdient
haben und es sind 147 dollar und 20 cent
ich finde das kann sich sehen lassen für
mich persönlich hat sich das jetzt wenn
man den zeitaufwand in anbetracht nicht
gelohnt gerade in der ersten woche
verdient man am wenigstens dauert eine
weile bis sich das aufbauen aber selbst
das was wir in dieser woche für den
haben wären für ein schüler schon
richtig gutes taschengeld oder sogar auf
jeden der arbeit in richtig guter
nebenverdienst steckt erst auf den link
in der mitte beschreibung ein test des
heftes zwei wochen gratis wenn ihr eure
ordnung auf das nächste level bringen
wollt oder wenn ihr einfach genauso
vielseitig und wenn du mich jetzt auf
dieser reise begleiten möchte dann
abonniert gern diesen kanal und dann
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
macht's gut
[Musik]